and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12
pursuant to executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there is no fiscal
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with emergency
order
the emergency order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff
have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting
by the zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available
in the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar
on the general court website the notice
for this meeting complies with house
rules
and rsa 91 a anyone who has a problem
accessing the meeting should email lba
underscore fiscal at leg
dot state dot nh dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting
the meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
lba staff are on the meeting assisting
us
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting
shall be done by roll call let's start
the meeting by
taking a roll call attendance when each
member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting which is required
under the right to know law
so representative lin if you would call
the rule
yes thank you madam chair uh
representative bucco
yes thank you i am present i'm at home
at my home in conway and there's no one
else in the house
all right representative danielson is
not here representative heath
good morning uh mayor heath here in
manchester at my home
and i'm here alone and i'm
representative lynn
uh i'm uh here at my home in windham and
i'm
alone in the room my wife is elsewhere
in the house
uh representative murray good morning
everyone kate murray is here in
newcastle
you already heard the dog and david's in
the basement
[Laughter]
uh representative petry uh
thank you i'm actually my wife's
roaming around i'm representing petrie
my dog was barking because kate's dog
was
a representative murray was barking
reacting to that so
she's around here somewhere thank you
and representative umberger
yes good morning a i don't have a dog b
i don't have a cat or gerbil or anything
else
but i am in my home in uh in kearsarge
my husband is in the house but not in
the room
all right uh thank you
okay uh thank you very much so
i see that tammy is hiding behind the um
you're just really not i just can't
i see um you should be able to uh start
your video
maybe in the bottom left tammy is there
like a an option to toggle your video
there you go thank you i tried to do it
up on the white side and it wouldn't let
me do anything
well good morning tammy i'm glad to uh
i'm glad to see you
oh i'm sure that uh
[Music]
so mickey there may be some other folks
in the waiting room as well at some
point so i think caitlyn's out there and
maybe steve is out there too if we need
to bring them in at a certain point
just let me know if at any time you want
okay yeah we're we're all here we're
here yeah okay so i'll go ahead and jump
in
yep great so happy to be here um this is
a follow-on to
our previous kind of overview of the
budget that we provided to you
to answer very specific questions as
well
i wanted to start out with there are a
couple of changes that we
are requesting in the budget and we
provided that information to mickey
and not really an unusual um development
in the sense that
you know when we start doing these
budgets we do them quite a long time in
advance and so stuff happens
uh over time and we need to we find that
we're in a position of needing to adjust
it
one of those adjustments that we are
asking for
is a uh a position in our bureau of
credentialing
and this is associated with our bus
driver
uh credentialing that was a bill that
was passed in the last legislative
session
and it became effective on january 1st
so we couldn't
apply for a position to put it into our
budget
because we didn't have uh the bill
hadn't gone into effect yet so we
couldn't apply to
dop to get the position that happened on
january one we've applied and gotten the
position or we're getting the position
so now we just need to add the funding
for this bus driver
credentialing person so just for
contacts for those of you who are not
through that
previous legislative session presently
background checks on school bus drivers
are performed
locally at each individual district this
sometimes results in a hardship to the
districts
and the bus drivers in the sense that
you may have a bus driver who drives for
multiple districts
in fact i was on the call this morning
about a bus driver incident a bus driver
who drives for two separate districts
and as a result of that the way the
current the previous law had read
that bus driver had to get two separate
background checks one from each district
in which they drove because they were
not permitted to share that information
between districts
and so they have consolidated that
activity at the
agency and so we will be running the
back
the bus driver background checks going
forward and
the second item that i wanted to bring
to your attention is a position that we
have
in one of our bureaus that we want to
move to a different bureau
this is part of what i would refer to as
kind of ongoing reorganization
and so we will be consolidating some of
our activities in our bureau of learner
support
and wanted to move a position that we
place in the organization to be able to
facilitate that
um and so you'll see that transfer as
well
that we've put there for you and then
the last item
that we had shared with you are two
that grant received after the budgeting
process
primarily because they had to go through
a an mou process with the department of
health and human services
and these are grants associated with our
promising future grants that we are
making to schools as well as our purple
star
grant program this is a funding that
comes to us
through the um
[Music]
the bdas so the bureau of drug and
alcohol
activities they provided a grant to us
via
health and human services to provide
support to schools for
preventative funding programs and so
that is the other
item and i think when we sent that over
to you we also included the
um fiscal items that would have gone
through the fiscal
process as well um so those are three
um of the the modifications that i think
we
are going to ask that if you can help us
just tune up our budget going into this
process that would be helpful to us um
and
with that said i will then pause and
really can kind of respond to
questions that you may have about the
rep representative thank you madam chair
um and thank you commissioner just could
you um talk a little bit more about the
changes in positions
that you just described sure so
there's in are you talking about the
last one that we talked about
yes yeah so this is a position it's an
admin for
that is in the bureau of uh it's in the
title 4b bureau
and then tammy where is it going to like
the bureau of instructional support is i
think where it goes to exactly
yeah so this is a position mary i'm just
going back a little bit you might
remember you had
julie couch who's overseeing the
the assessment and the title program so
excuse me i had to get some coffee no
worries at all
i mean i don't know if there are any
specific questions i mean we can
follow up on some of the questions that
we had from the last time
i have had um some variety of different
outreach specifically around the dual
and concurrent so i but i know that
that's a topic of conversation and
everybody's having dialogue around it
i'm happy to answer any additional
questions um at the department we still
believe that that's a program better
housed
through the community college system
than at the department because we're
really just a pass-through organization
um not adding value to that process and
so
i would encourage that that to be
a program embedded at community college
maybe more than the department of
education
um because essentially we just get an
invoice from them and then we pay the
invoice
so representative heath
oh thank you madam chair um it is so
disappointing about dual enrollment i
actually was just having a conversation
with someone this morning about that
um and i've spoken with susan heward and
best
dorian from the program i am really
hopeful that we can do something because
the impact will be 6 000
students that have benefited from that
program
over the years and it just it makes such
a huge difference
to families because so many kids go on
to college and have those extra credits
so um anything that you can do from your
side would be appreciated and hopefully
we can do something from our side
but um if i may madam chair i do have a
couple of
questions um on the first section of the
budget if i may
um absolutely this is kind of a
free uh a free time to ask
any questions that we have because um
this will more than likely be the uh
the last day other than for
um doe you know if we have
specific questions as we're going
through the
um finalization of uh
of the budget and um so we'll
we'll see so please go ahead thank you
ma'am cheer
i think my question is going to be for
tammy in combination with the
commissioner
but there are increases in the general
fund lines
in the office of the commissioner and in
the office of the deputy commissioner
and i was wondering if you could just
describe um
why there are those increases and the
changes
um that are happening there please thank
you
and is there a specific page that you
want to focus on
well um we've got um page
wait a second yes for the office of the
commissioner
i want you to lock the page i'm sorry
um i think it's uh uh yeah it's the next
page
just in the line of the it's gone from
um
well in 90 um in 2021
1.2 almost 1.3 million and it go
oh well actually it's it's not that big
increase so is that the new position
that you added to your staff no i don't
think so tammy can weigh in if i just go
back up i think what you're going to
find is
that you see in the personnel so both
you know we had raises so as you know
that there's the normal step increases
that people are
awarded okay as well as the benefit
costs are increasing
i'm just going through the different
line items
you know so the biggest is there's about
a 36 000
increases in step increases for the
people who are in the
office of the commissioner which is
going to include i believe the
commissioner our communications person
um our administrative uh support and who
else is in there tammy
uh the receptionist and the receptionist
and actually so that might be driving
some of the three representatives of its
receptionist because if you recall
um that was a position that was unfilled
for a period of time
and was cost shared among some of the
other bureaus
i think probably that's when you were
here remember like every every bureau
used to kick in a little bit
for the reception um and really it was
difficult to
to manage that from a compliance
standpoint because of the federal funds
that were coming in there
so now this is a fully funded in the
general funds type of
makes good sense and is as it should be
and
in the office of the deputy uh now that
general fun line
has increased um from 635
000 now to 740 000. what are the changes
in that line from please
so most of this is around is if you'll
see where we're driving it if you go
just up half you can see there's some
decline
some increases and some decreases so we
took out
some funding out of the professional
development specific to
staff members at the department
primarily because people we had put a
certain amount in
and it wasn't being used as much as we
thought it was going to be used
where we were paying for people who take
post-secondary opportunities and stuff
like that we are continuing to encourage
professional development around stuff
like you know getting your excel skills
up to speed
um in particular a lot of adobe work is
going on because we're doing a lot of
workflow stuff in terms of automation
but then if you go down into the
contracts what you'll see is there's a
communications
increase and this is we've got our kind
of a full-time communications person
but what we've discovered is that
getting messaging out
to people um is just vitally important
particularly
in the pandemic we've discovered how
important it is and so we're working
primarily with cookson
to do a variety of like pdf type
documents
that we allow uh the schools to have
to communicate stuff i think i might
have shared with you last time
one that we did around the food and
nutrition how we created a
like a document that the schools could
use to send home to
their families about the importance of
signing up for free and reduced lunch
stuff
um so and then for example at noon today
i'll be sharing a document
uh around the educator vaccinations
right so what we've really done is kind
of professionalize some of this
communication to make it easier
for for us as well as the schools to get
a consistent message out to the whole
population and i don't know if
i have screen share i can give you an
example of what one of those might look
like if that's helpful
would i don't know if that'd be useful
yes commissioner i would appreciate that
okay let me get i'm going to show you
one that this is how you guys shouldn't
be sharing this with me yet because it
hasn't gone public but i'm gonna
this is i don't think there's too many
people paying attention here so as an
example
here's what we'll be sharing with our
school leaders i think you should be
able to see
that right now yes phase 2a
yes yeah so these are the kinds of
things that we put together
that we then provide to the schools and
then we put you know you can put them
out on social media
and it's like who and how you get done
and how you get the vaccine and stuff
like that so
these are the types of um
documents that we anticipate being able
to
share with people to be able to just
make sure everybody stayed on the same
page
uh representative petrie you have a
question
could if we could um let's just stay
with the commissioner and the deputy
commissioner
until everybody has asked all the
questions that they uh
want to ask on that so joe is your
question
on the commissioner or deputy
commissioner yeah
it uh thank you madam chair uh uh
welcome again uh commissioner frank uh
you've been here before um the question
is uh
what are your concerns on the emergency
between the community college system
and the university system so i'm
actually quite
comfortable with the uh the proposal by
the governor to do that and i think that
the way that he has done that um is
in such a way that we don't have to
answer all of the questions but if you
think about the primary driver here
is a combined oversight board between
the community college
system and the university system and
then
that collective board is then able to
work out a lot of the details in terms
of what that might look like
i have been an advocate all along for
creating
uh you know seamless pathways for uh
students in our system
and i think that this is a a policy that
is
also consistent with that of in terms of
trying to create
seamless pathways for students to be
able to move forward
um i don't know that we've necessarily
worked out all of the details
nor do i know that we have to but
because by creating that combined board
we really create a governance structure
that can move forward those policies to
allow
um you know the objectives of seamless
uh you know access as well as some of
the concerns that people have about
integrating two systems
that would be my perspective excuse me
madam chair um
as i think i mentioned to you i'm gonna
have to leave for a little at least a
little while i have
two hearings on my bills but i'll be
back as soon as i can and i apologize uh
to the members of the committee and to
the commissioner and his assistant
thank you representative no problem
whatsoever uh representative petry has
to leave as well so
okay uh representative murray you had a
question
yes thank you madam chair just um
clarifying two things that uh from
representative heath
um on 1193 there is a third position
there is that the combined position that
um commissioner you were talking about
tammy you're muted sorry
sorry that's the receptionist the
commissioner was talking about that's
the combined position thing okay and the
other
um the contracts those are that was
really interesting what you showed i'm
glad you showed that because that really
kind of clarified what you were talking
about and that's cooks and
communications
that's who we have right now just
you know point of interest his dad
taught me advanced music theory
okay i do have a question on
this is on uh page
1 119 5
which is dealing with the national
how is that i assume it's distributed to
the communities
that have um national forest as part of
their
life how do we
distribute that money to
the towns so it is a formula grant i
don't know
yes when we receive those funds from the
feds they actually tell us who we need
to distribute those funds to
and there's an individual in my office
that reaches out to the towns if there's
any question as to whether or not it's
going to
a district or if it's going directly to
the town
so it's not one answer if it's all it
depends on the
okay are there any further questions
there
all right seeing none uh
okay um sorry representative murray
um can you just speak briefly to i see i
know their federal funds but um it looks
like it's a new grant for preschool
development on 1198
can you just give a few words about what
that means that looks i mean i'm down
with preschool education here
yeah so this was a grant that um
we had done a combination of university
of new hampshire
department of education department of
health and human services
uh we applied for that grant and won it
we're now about 18 months into that
award that we won that grant
so it wasn't in our previous budget but
obviously it's going to be in this
budget going forward
um and it's again work on preschool
development grant is what is referred to
and it's working on our uh
early childhood education efforts
it was a fairly sizable grant about 33
yeah yeah so the 93 that's here
is just your part of it that's correct
so most of it is run
through the university system of new
hampshire
so they are the fiduciary for the grant
and this is our
staff so in the grant we wrote up
certain positions
at the department to manage our portion
of that along with the staff from
hhs has some people in it as well as the
university system has
the bulk of the funding associated with
them
okay thank you and mostly if it
matters most of that funding so this is
some staff level positions but most of
the money is passed through to
uh community grants of that around
various uh setting up systems
um on a go-forward basis
thank you madam chair um can i
jump ahead to um analytics
yeah is that all right
just just tell us the page all right i
am
on page um
and this is um the line
at the bottom general funds where
um there's a bump
there from 407 to 669 just wondering
if that's a new system or or
what is happening there so i think that
the primary driver is really around um
some positions you'll see we went from
two to four
and if you go up to the top you just
look at the personnel you had nothing in
there and went from 36k
to 200 000. and really much of that is
around
some of the restructuring that was
taking place and filling positions
that had not been filled in the past
around
accountability as an example was one of
them um
and there's another one caitlyn might be
on and she might want to jump in and
weigh in on this if you want to look for
her mickey
um in fact i'm gonna pause for a minute
and just see if she's there she wants to
hi caitlyn yes i did um so those were
actually just positions that were in a
different accounting unit that were
moved over to this accounting unit um so
it was just part of the
the organization they're not new
positions and they actually were not
unfilled positions in the last budget
they just weren't necessarily in the
appropriate place in the
um 20 and 21 budget so thank you that's
great
i appreciate it and while katelyn's here
can i ask one more
question madam cheer please oh
absolutely
on page 1209 technology software
um this um actually it went down
but then i was that a purchase that you
made
in um 21 and then um
there's a 401 000 in 22
and 375 in 23 is that
um the cost to sustain that piece of
software
no that is not um so the 401 and the 375
is actually our ongoing software that we
have had
continuously so things like our ireport
our tableau software things that we've
been working with um
the large purchase was we are have been
working strategically to upgrade the
student information system and the
department of education will need
a finding level of that additional one
and a half million dollars to maintain
a new student information software
however we
were not given that money right now in
this version of the budget so we will
not be able to maintain a new student
information system at this level
and we did have some luck with applying
for
federal money to purchase the system
and so we are looking to release the rfp
momentarily right now for the new system
but we will need to increase funding
levels to be able to maintain that
system going forward
so representative you may recall in that
previous budget
this was one of our prioritized needs so
we still believe that it's something
that's important to
the agency it's important to the state
and as i often like to point out
it will save many years of time for our
school district it will improve our
ability to
get you good and timely information and
it will improve data security for our
students
um so we think it's a good thing and
that's why it's in our prioritized list
but it wasn't we weren't able to fit it
into our
the parameters of our budget that we had
received from the governor's office
thank you commissioner um if madame
champ if i may
i'm sorry absolutely please um caitlyn
um what does this mean to school
districts
um so it's a little background
information
um so our current system it's called i4c
it's a proprietary software to the state
of new hampshire
um it was developed i believe maybe when
you were at the department or
even prior it was 2001 and so 20 years
ago
and when we first originally developed
this software we were a leader in the
country as far as student data
collection systems because it's an
internally developed system
there has not been a lot of continuing
operations costs so that's
obviously a bonus for the state um but
now we are
here um 20 years later and there's a lot
better systems that are available
that the state of new hampshire really
should be taking advantage of many of
the school districts across the state
have
gone on their own and invested in
student information systems
and then they would be if the state of
new hampshire had a better system
available be able to
integrate automatically into our system
and be able to
report information to us without having
to do a lot of the manual work that
school districts are having to do now
so right now for school to say if you
were to have a new collection
for school so say you want to know all
the kids that have blue eyes for example
in the schools
the department of education would have
to contract with a vendor to modify our
system
train then provide training to school
districts
then have the school districts have
their own internal reports developed
download those upload them to our system
and then spend a lot of time validating
the data across the different school
districts
if we had better systems at the state
level all of that could be automated and
you wouldn't need the excess staff time
at the school districts nor the
department of education staff time
that's spent
which would mean not only less time but
it would mean a higher quality of data
being reported automatically to the
state
and i will just point out as well like
this is my third attempt at this one
because i do think
again it's just going to make
everybody's lives easier
and uh and if you imagine i didn't
actually remember
came in that the other system was
developed back in like 2001.
i mean in tech talk that's a long time
ago
so are you telling me the
where's the number um
it's line 38 on page 1209 prioritize
needs item that they are discussing
okay so you're saying that this
uh
change hands the figure of 401
you said you've applied for a federal
grant
to take care of the purchase
of the software yes so
and then the 401 would be
for licensing and
whatever else is that correct no so
um at the current levels that you're
seeing right there the 401
that does not include operating a new
system that is just operating our
current systems when we need to contract
out for a vendor
for some of our other current systems
that we have that are up and going
um in our prioritized needs budget we do
not have the operating expenses
the what in the past um
you have seen a similar request in the
capital budget as to our operating
budget for an additional two million
dollars
so that would be the initial purchase
and then this line right here that you
see is the ongoing operations of the
additional 1.5 million dollars um so
if you look in our capital budget we
don't have a request for the two million
dollars in the capital budget because we
have been successful in obtaining
federal money to the for the initial
purchase
um but we do not have the ongoing
operating costs covered
and how much is that it's about we
estimate it to be about 1.5 million
dollars a year um it can vary
um we're going to have hopefully results
back from our rfp shortly
and the the part that is kind of up in
the air is how many school districts
choose to use the state system because
one of the things that we're hoping to
be able to do
is offer the school districts the
ability to use the state system at a
reduced or
zero cost to the school districts um
and then that would give us some
purchasing power and obviously save some
money for the by the school districts
so that is kind of one of the up in the
air
type things about really figuring out
what the cost would be right now
and i guess refund burger one of the
things along that line too and caitlin i
don't recall the actual per pupil
amounts but
for example if we were to have a
statewide system a typical district may
be paying
you know upwards of 15 ahead per kid to
be able to use a
you know if they buy their own license
but if we were to do a consolidated
system
then we might be able to get it for as
much as eight dollars so
while it is true that we would be paying
for
excuse me we would be paying for those
license costs at the state we would
actually save the education system
you know more than you know the cost of
okay thank you uh representative heath
representative murray thank you
um i thought i was following along and
then i got confused again
um so
you haven't purchased this new software
yet
and you don't have when you say maintain
is that actually um
what you need in order to use the
software or is it what you need in order
to continually main
upgrade and maintain the software going
forward so is it
maintained in terms of using it now or
maintained going forward with upgrades
um so the two million dollars that we
received federal money that's the
initial purchase that's installation on
our systems that's installation on
school district systems and the various
professional development
that comes on training the various
schools to use the system
the 1.5 that we would need would be the
ongoing software
licensing cost to continue using our
systems
that we hope to depend depending on the
vendor would cover things
like when the legislature proposes new
legislation
the the software would likely come with
maintenance agreements
that they are automatically including
have to include those new reports at no
additional costs
the school districts have those types of
um deals in their current contracts and
we would hopefully have that too
so it would be the ongoing operations
updating of the system everything should
be included in that licensing phase
so federally you have the grant funds
for the software
and to purchase use the software you
need us to provide money to use it yes
exactly it'd be tough to get it and not
be able to use it
right you don't want to do that no
that's not a good idea we need the whole
package but
i mean again we've asked for the package
a couple of times and we didn't get it
but we found this grant so we've applied
for it anything we can do to
you know offset the cost we will
okay next
is there anything else that uh
people want to uh okay
uh representative heath you have
actually
covered all of my questions so so far
so good on you um my question
is about thank you madam chair and thank
you commissioner
um this is my budget that i know the
best
um terms you have seven positions that
you're requesting
um could you describe those positions
and the purpose of each um and
the long range uh look at um
how what the potential is for those
continued funding
uh source yeah so there's the seven
positions are comprised of two
categories
um the first is five positions for the
disability determination service dds
and so these are positions that the
social security administration has
requested
that we expand our capacity to do those
to provide those services
those positions would only be available
to the extent that they are funded right
if the federal funds go away
then those positions would also go away
the other two positions that we have
is we have two charter school funded
positions
and these also come to us through a
federal grant so the
uh 46 million dollar charter school
grant that we received
the grant application included two
positions in it to administer that grant
and so these are included in that and
similar to the dds work if that grant
goes away for some reason then these
positions would also go away
thank you commissioner if i may madam
chair one more
absolutely in terms of those two
positions
um one of the things that when i was at
the department many years ago
we were able to do some reviews and
um oversight for the charter schools
what is going to be the and then funding
was eliminated and and there was really
not a lot of oversight um because
of the grant that you got and the
increase in numbers of charters
what kind of oversight do you see
happening
as a result of all these new positions
yep so well
so certainly there's two aspects of that
so these two charter school positions
are written into the grant
that are really designed around this
this is a startup grant so these are
positions that will be working with the
schools
to be able to get going for ongoing
schools that are either doing a
replication or an expansion grant they
would support them
these positions another aspect of the
grant is what's referred to as best
practices
so they would have responsibility to
propagate those best practices
in all of our schools whether those be
charter schools or traditional public
schools to make sure that
that information gets out these would
not be specific
monitoring types of positions we do have
and over the last couple of years
have been putting in place monitoring
processes
so for example also within caitlin's
bureau she has a
a bureau of compliance that does
compliance monitoring of
our grantees both all of our schools
um and and looks at those and that
program
you know has been stood up for probably
about 18 months now can you correct me
if i'm wrong
um and so we have been executing against
that and it has been
effective in terms of helping to make
sure that we have
federal compliance like compliance with
all the federal grants
and then as well we are
now having our other compliance which is
accountability compliance is the way to
describe
it which means that we've got schools
that are complying with the state
educational you know regulations um
and that work we actually have a
position that we have hired it's been
difficult to find somebody who has that
position
we have an individual who is a uh i
think they're a principal in the school
right now will be coming to us
at the end of this contract here and
we'll be able to begin to do that work
so uh we i feel like we have the
compliance work
um you know that is happening but in
these two particular
uh funds are mostly tied to the grand
activity
thank you commissioner and um one more
question
related to assessment of charges but
also assessment of our public school
students
what is the assessment methodology right
now please
yep so caitlin do you want to weigh in
on that or otherwise i can take it but
yeah sure um so just like when you were
in the department we had the k
through or sorry the three through eight
and eleven assessment in math
english language arts and science and we
still have that same assessment
um in 2015 we switched from our new
hampshire kneecap to the
smarter balance assessment and in 2019
or maybe 18 i believe 18. so we switched
um
from smarter balance which was owned by
air
um the national assessment consortium um
to
new hampshire sas which is very similar
owned by the same exact consultant
assessment firm very similar to that
it's just kind of a new hampshire
specific attests whereas smarter balance
was more of a name brand
and so we continue to implement that
assessment
the assessment um we are you know
working on exactly what that's going to
look like given the pandemic and whatnot
this year
um and various changes that are being
required and or allowed by the federal
government but that's the the process
that we continue to
to use and we haven't really changed
that at all
as far as our general assessments so and
the charter schools are required to take
the exact same assessment that all of
our public schools in the state of new
hampshire
are required to take great thank you and
the cost is still
shared federal and state
yeah yes thank you
paid for entirely by the state though
not the school district so school
districts don't incur any costs
relative to the assessment thank you
representative petrie you have a
question
no i just uh like i planned uh i have to
leave but
i want to thank the education department
for uh
efficiency and cost effectiveness of
their program uh
is really impressive thank you thank you
thank you very much representative petry
are there other questions from anyone
besides me
okay um let's go back to
i got my right thing here um
you had indicated that you were going to
add
a position in credentialing or you
wanted to add
a position in credent credentialing
but yet when you explained
the jump from 287 to 294
you attributed all of that increase
to federal programs
so susan
tell me where tell me what i'm missing
here um
so the 287 to 294 is an increase of
seven and that increase of seven
includes the five
social security disability
administration and the two
charter school physicians i'm now coming
to you and saying
by the way after i finish my budget i
need another position for the bus driver
credentialing
so there's this new law that went into
effect in january
and so then we went to dop to get the
position
um and because what is going to happen
is at the department of education
we will now be running background checks
for
school bus drivers so it's really
not seven it's eight including that one
but that one was kind of a late entry
into the process and that's why you're
okay i guess i i guess i must have
missed that conversation i apologize
so that was that beginning conversation
of one of those modifications that we
need
like as you're working on the budget
there were three things that we needed
um that we think need to be added to the
budget one is for that
uh the bus driver the other is for the
transfer of the one position from one
bureau
to the bureau of instructional support
and then the third is to be able to
get appropriation associated with the
promising futures
grants and the purple star program and
so those are all
activities that took place post-budget
submission and so i'm just saying like
if we can add those now then that would
be
helpful uh have you forwarded that
information to mickey and i just missed
it
we did i think he has it okay so that
was
mickey that was what you sent yesterday
yep
yeah okay okay i i looked at it quickly
but
um i didn't uh now i know i need to uh
look at a little more and correct me if
i'm around cami but i think the bus
driver position is
it's gonna be other funds funded right
in other words through the bureau of
credentialing
um if that's germane
that is correct and and
for clarification in reality that
position
was approved january 1st so it
technically is in our budget right now
or it's not really in the budget but it
is a position that is available to the
department
today we just simply did not include it
in the credentialing budget that was
submitted during the agency phase
because we did not have it available to
us so that's why we provided you a new
budget for fy
22 and 23 for the credentialing budget
because
um the inclusion of that position
actually changes a lot
of the other classes in that account
so if you look on page 1226 you'll see
the
uh credentialing accounting unit 9008 on
page 1226
and tammy perhaps you want to share your
screen with the requested budget that
you'd like to put in place of what is
in the governor's recommended budget
just so the committee will kind of
here
hit share yeah we can see it okay
okay um so there were increases
to not just the class 10 and the class
60 but
um we needed to increase things like um
rent and the telecommunications
and um we needed to increase our
contracts because the inclusion of this
position
in the credentialing budget also means
that we need to
do some software changes to our software
so essentially what what the
department's looking to do
is replace what you see in the
governor's recommended budget on page
1226 for that credentialing accounting
unit
with the account uh with the budget that
you see on the shared screen from tammy
so
and like the commissioner said these are
not general funds this is a
restricted revolving fund the
credentialing fund that funds this
accounting unit so there would be no
impact on your
general fund picture for the division to
do this change
representative murray you have a
question yeah just so i'm following
along so
on 1227 you have the um
total source of funds is 1725
278 and that will change to two zero one
two
zero four three all right is that right
now we have a uh i know we have a
footnote
footnote i know we have a footnote here
that says
um you know these
these monies need to stay within this do
we know how much
money is actually in this fund
and can it absorb
this new position without
a corresponding
increase to credentialing fees
so ordinarily i might say yes
representative except that what we did
is
we reduced our educator licensure fees
based on a model to bleed off any
potential excess so
if we don't fund this position then
ultimately we would probably have to
reverse some of that feed reduction that
we've just provided to the educators
uh because you probably can't before you
vote like i can't reduce the fees and
increase the cost simultaneously
it would accelerate the bleed off of any
so did i just hear you say that
that you had thought you were going to
reduce the fees but with this new person
you won't be able to
no what i'm saying is i already did
reduce the fees last spring
and so that fee reduction because i had
i was accumulating some funds in this
account and this is
again the teachers pay their fees and
i'm only trying to
charge them what it costs me so we
reduced the fees in the spring
then we got this bill that will result
in an increased cost so
i think it might be improving to
continue
to have a fee reduction and an increase
in cost so i think it's better to just
leave the fee reduced than to
have this added to the budget
so if i understood what you said which
obviously i didn't
the first time you reduced the fees
in last year yeah and you had been
planning to reduce the fees again
we were re-looking at those options okay
okay
but because of your adding this position
you won't reduce the fees this coming
year
um i don't think so we're just going to
continue to look at it and see anytime
that i can
create the reduction i will but right
now i don't think so
okay so this is kind of a
so in this area you've already
increased from 10
to 11. and so now you're asking to go
positions this is on uh yeah
you're on page uh 12 27. we're adding
the
one additional uh position no because i
think
cammy you said that i already have the
position
but i didn't go ahead and i'm gonna let
tammy describe that
because it's kind of this weird thing
there's like a doughnut haul you get the
authorization but you don't actually
have the dop authorization kind of thing
so
right i believe that she
represented berger i believe you are
correct we will go to
okay
okay thank you very much will and
yeah you've got that for me someplace
right and mickey has that yeah
you've sent it you've sent it to me it's
been sent to the the committee
online too if the public is looking for
this information
okay all right sounds sounds good
okay are there any other questions
from the group
okay let me
let me find my questions here
um commissioner
i guess that you are um have done
a lot of rearranging of positions
throughout the um the budget
and i assume that that's because you're
doing
a um
and what do i want to call it um yeah
a reorganization so i would say that
there's a combination of
stuff there's not a ton of the
reorganization but i think and tammy
maybe you want to weigh in on this as
well
we did create some new accounting unit
type of control so that we had greater
visibility and transparency into some of
the activities that are going on
yes yes so for example when caitlin was
talking
earlier during the reorg she we had
the accounting units during the last
budget and
she inserted positions where she thought
they were going to be but throughout the
last two years
it um some of the positions just needed
to be moved they're still within
her division but she just needed to move
them into more appropriate accounting
units
it's no problem i just wanted to make
sure that that's that's
what it was all about uh representative
murray you have a question
i was wondering on 12 33 if those change
of positions is the is an example of
what you're talking about
um it went from four positions to two
this is under instructional suppression
where
was that an example of or did you
actually lose those positions
this is this is one of these positions
that was moved
is the position that the commissioner is
requesting
it reinstated into this same exact
account
so instead of going from four down to
two it would go from four down to
three because we would move a position
that
is in another accounting unit back into
this accounting unit
so there were two positions that were
lost but you're going to move one back
from another accounting unit
so this will actually be three jimmy do
you know what the other position is
not off the top of my head i don't know
i apologize also if you go to page 1254
you'll see the other side of this
conversation
right the title 4b is where we removing
that
aventfort position out of to be kind of
oversight of some of this stuff right
nikki you're amazing
[Music]
that's why we have them here and we like
so so i guess i mean essentially we move
stuff around to try to be
efficient in terms of who's where make
sure we have good accountability
but then also just some of the the
accounting unit stuff to make sure that
okay are there any other questions
all right i do have a question on page
um you're showing
a office of the comm
deputy commissioner printing revolving
fund
and the source of revenue is result
revolve revolving funds
now i understand that
they're setting up a revolving fund in
bas
for printing is this something
so this is our copier fund in our
printing fund here at the department
we i'm sorry jimmy you're not you're not
clear
i'm not yeah your mic isn't working all
yes yeah okay um
that's our copier account here at the
department
so we rent copiers we use this
fund to um pay for the copiers and then
we cross allocate from all of the
programs
okay that makes that makes sense to me
this did not make sense because of
what was said in um in the
i made notes here and uh don't worry
go through them okay
which is veteran education services
state
and we have a um
money from uh the feds
to support this so what are we doing
[Music]
with the uh the state funds
since this was not there in the last
budget
so tammy you can weigh in as well but i
think it was in the last budget but this
is one of those where we try to separate
out so we could have clean accounting
associated with it
because we do run the veterans fund
which is basically
from this is the right accounting unit
in the career schools where we
you have to certify all of the programs
associated with
uh the education programs for veterans
and we are funded for much of that work
through federal funds but i don't think
this is new is it
tammy it is i don't know um
it's on to be perfectly honest the
federal government's not giving us
funding sufficiency we carve down okay
yeah yeah
um and because they're not giving us
sufficient funds
for the overhead um we put this in as a
general funded request to help support
that program
in the various areas of like information
technology
you know current expenses things
that that the the veterans program uses
a sliding scale for
what they allow the department to charge
for overhead cost
operating cost and it's not sufficient
to
support the program
honestly it was either do this or
um
we have gone back to the veterans um
administration
a couple of times telling them that
there's not enough administrative
support
to pay for our activities
we have those efforts have not been met
positively
they've not said that they would allow
us to have any kind of an increased
funding
and i think the whole budget is only
about 157 thousand families
right and so then they give you a
certain amount of administrative
support that's just not enough to pay
for the cost
especially if you have staff who are in
those positions
i apologize for the way i'm losing my
voice
yeah i i see on page 1220
it's uh 2 37
and then it goes up to 247 the following
year
and so what you're saying
doesn't provide sufficient dollars to
operate the program that
we need an additional 8 000
and 7.8
you're muted timmy oh i'm sorry
you're open now your mic is still not
working that great that's all you said i
heard i saw you say no but i didn't hear
anything no
she you are correct representative
humber
the next one down is the uh
scholarship for orphans and vets
uh it looks like we didn't do anything
in
20 but we did in 21
and then you're asking again for it
in 22 and 23.
so
anyhow tell tell me what i know but
i know that the program is a scholarship
program
for
children whose parents have died while
serving in the military exactly either
while
serving or if it's service related if
it's a service connection where if they
die after but it's service related
then every year we run a variety of
programs to try and
identify candidates for this scholarship
because it is relatively narrowly scoped
we have not always been able to award
the scholarships because there's no
eligible
individuals that meet the criteria for
this request
and we have you know coordinated with
the adjutant general
to try and identify these folks and do
everything we can to try and get it out
sometimes there is an eligible student
then we're happy to award and sometimes
there's not anybody who gets the
okay now this says that the uh the
sums appropriated will will be
non-lapsing
so how much do we currently have in
there
i think timmy knew you were gonna ask
i'll look it up and get right back to
you how fast okay that'll be fine
i'm just you know if i got what you're
saying
uh commissioner um that is difficult to
necessarily find people and that you
know maybe we could uh
move this 10 000 to dual and concur
enrollment
or so i think there may be some
limitations on the bequest
there's like you'd have to go back to
the original law i think we've actually
taken a look at that at one point in
time
that the law itself and we can go help
dig that up
enumerated how the bequest was supposed
to be used i think or something like
that
well it's not a bequest it's uh general
funds
yeah it has something tied to it i'm not
sure what that is but we can go take a
representative um
right now we have an available balance
we have spent twenty five hundred
this year um
i don't know what that means moving
forward but i believe typically it's a
four-year program so that may
indicate that we'd be spending another 2
500 for the next three years
right because generally right each year
the student gets an award
right i i understand that okay
thank you uh now let's move on to
[Music]
the next one down the new england
board of higher education scholarships
and grants
and you're asking for
147 000 there what is
that program all about yeah so that is
actually our
fees in uh nebby the new england board
of higher education
um and by participating in nebby
it allows new hampshire students to go
to
a another new england college at
in-state tuition rates
if the university system does not
provide
that particular major i don't disagree
that the sum is high
we have made several attempts to try and
negotiate are we really getting
our money's worth there are some
analyses that are done that
demonstrate that there are several
million dollars of
tuition savings to new hampshire
residents who
access this program so uh that is that
whole amount is basically our fee
so it's not really a scholarship it's a
it's a
uh it's a fee yeah it's more of a faith
aboard higher education okay
and this fee
i love fees this fee allows
um people to go to massachusetts maine
vermont
as long as none of the colleges here
offer that particular program is that
correct that's correct
right they get to go there at ins at
their in-state tuition
now is this both two and four-year
colleges
i can find out is steve steve apple be
on the phone
i'm gonna bring steve in here great so
steve is the division director for the
good morning steve did you hear the
question
um yes it does cover two-year as well as
four-year
and the fee also
pays for our participation in the
national
sarah agreement which is the reciprocal
agreement
that means we don't have to review every
single out-of-state college program
that's offered in our state and our
colleges that offer outside of our state
don't have to be reviewed in those
states so it saves
our institutions funds and it saves the
department
okay now that uh
okay this is the um
the educators support
for the higher education commission
it's uh chose 269.
can we talk about that sure can you just
give me a um
a page in the line i know oh yeah 225
12 20. yeah yeah 12 25 is
uh the estimated sorts of funds for
higher education commission
um and so these are the personnel steve
i don't know if you want to weigh in on
this but this
it looks like it's driven principally by
our personnel
that support the division of higher
education
yes um thank you this is primarily the
two positions my position
um as well as an unclassified position
that support the division as well as the
higher education commission
which is the body that of course
the hedc rules roll up to and that
commission has rule making authority and
consists of
college presidents and some lay folks
and they handle all of the
post-secondary
okay so the the cost
is because of
the employee yes
yes and steve is one of those employees
right so he's definitely
any cuts on his line okay
so what other
commissions do you work with or is this
well as division director i also oversee
the bureau of credentialing
the bureau of educator preparation the
veteran state approvals that we were
speaking of earlier
the office of career school licensing
the bus driver background check position
will be
within the bureau of credentialing in my
division
as well as the council for teacher
education
at council for teacher education the
professional standards board
we supported those two boards
okay so did you charge your entire
salary here
okay
so this is just one of the things that
uh that you manage you're not full time
doing this right so i oversee the entire
division
but it's paid for out of this account my
salary
okay thank you
let me see how i i need to make a note
so rep on burger are you thinking that
you know maybe we ought to do some cost
allocations into
you know credentialing or something like
that no i'm i'm not thinking that i'm
just trying to understand
um i i just thought for a board
that wasn't uh paid this was kind of
a uh a figure that
i i certainly didn't understand
so that that's kind of where i'm coming
from no
it i unders i agree that it's difficult
stuff across the board
the idea people
um
i guess that most
is at most of what goes on with this
group
the checking of the
you've gone you what
oh i'm sorry i guess i'm not
i said are there other things well
maybe i should just ask what is what is
the
general workload of
these 21 people that are
in the special education
for elementary and secondary
um so does this include my federal
funding as well
yeah so this includes a combination of
um you know we receive
about 40 plus million dollars of federal
idea funds plus we get about 30 million
dollars
of state funds so part of it is
allocating those funds out to
the various uh schools because most of
this is pass-through funding to the
schools
uh we then provide technical support to
the schools in terms of how they will
use those funds for the most part those
funds are set up in our grant management
system so
a district will fill out a grant
application saying here's how i intend
to use
my special education funds we'll review
those applications and ensure
that all of their intended uses are
eligible
then as the districts complete those
activities
they will report them as completed we
will approve or authorize those
completed activities as being eligible
um so that they can then get paid and
then the final piece of that is that we
do monitoring so we're actually going
out to
the districts and going through and
really doing an audit of their special
education processes to make sure that
they are
complying with the quite extensive rules
around special education both state and
federal
um and then i think the last piece that
you'll have in there is
um around a uh complaint
resolution so we do have a full-time
person who is managing
um special education complaints from
parents and really just
trying to help them navigate uh you know
through the various
mitigation or mediation type processes
that we have
um so that they can come to a resolution
with their districts
okay thank you very much um
let's go on to uh 1238
and the court ordered placements
uh i wish representative lynn was here
but
um on the on the court ordered
placements
what i guess
i guess my my question is
where what causes a court-ordered
placement
um that um
that you know that obviously can't be
handled and it's more than
it's more than uh a school problem
it's so i just i i
because i know we're showing uh
you know 2 million but
we also showed that it cost us 3.2
in in 20.
so um i just need some help with this
so um and i can get an expert at it i'll
try to explain it
at you know kind of a higher level but
there is some degree of detail
associated with it but
um i believe statutorily
uh when the court makes a
child a child placement um could be out
of district
and they say like this child is gonna
have to go to this home or this home
um and that includes an educational
component we're required to pay that
uh when those quoted replacements are
made
um you know they're made to
authorize locations it's not like they
just can
go to any old place but they do go to
very specific facilities um and then we
are
uh bill for those and
have to reimburse those costs uh for
this the child's placement there
so that's that's probably too high level
for you but yeah that's
that's uh that's i got that i knew that
but
i guess i'm looking at trying to figure
out the next level down
that um you know uh how many children do
we have in
court ordered placements what is the
general
reason for the court order um
you know are people
sending the kids to court rather than
taking care of it
um you know locally i mean i don't
i'll quit at that if you'll just get me
i'll get you the information i'll get
you some information on that happy to do
that
unless christine is on i don't know if
she wants to weigh in on it or not
no i think we should get the information
so we give the
exact facts but thanks to the question
i'd i really i really would appreciate
that
unless mickey is becky on ricky's not
only
is there a becky for dead or rebecca for
that on no yeah
i'll go with the air commissioner yeah
you can you can just
forward the information to us through
mickey that will be
on page 1242
you've got uh
state money for
so and where it's a new program
according to this
and it's um looking at
uh 190
000 and general funds
so can we have some discussion about
this
new program i didn't see
anything nearby unless it's
the the student
learner support system of care grant
if that's it or not but
camera you want to jump in yes i can
help on that
um that is a new accounting unit
that we took two positions
jimmy you're not you put your hands down
because it's not working it's really
hard for anybody
go ahead and talk how's that work does
that work
we move there was that is the um
division of learner support
administrative account
so we moved one of the positions over to
that student wellness so again this is
another
way like we did with caitlin's division
of just trying to align positions
into the correct accounting unit and
sometimes that requires us to create
accounting units and then move positions
over
and that's what we did in this instance
yeah i'm not concerned
about the positions i'm concerned about
the program
where did it come from because it wasn't
funded
before
so i think it may be the naming
conventions that i'm using when i
develop new accounting units
um so the program did exist before
but it was housed in uh the learner
support
account 6401 which
i'm sorry rep you're on mute sorry so
when i look at that i should see a
corresponding decrease of 190
and 202 when i look back at page
you said 234 231
uh 12 31 is where you'll see a decrease
we went from 614 down to 563
it will not often be exactly
corresponding because in the meantime we
have salary and benefit increases
okay so what you're telling me is that
the program
on page whatever it is 1242
was embedded in these dollars
but i can't say we don't have a new
program over there we're still running
basically our mtssd types of programs
through the
system of care and there's not a new
program
i i got that i was just trying to figure
let's see here
do we i know uh
indicated that um i think the number was
157 million
carissa act or whatever 156 million
okay what's a million dollars here and
there in that
when is the how is that going to go out
to the school districts
is it going out through they come in and
ask for it or is it going to be
distributed
across the
the school districts based on something
yeah so it will basically be distributed
through the grant management system to
the districts
on a formula allocation based on title
one
and i um with the when i met with you at
the overview i don't know if you recall
it was kind of like a high level summary
that i gave you on all these different
pieces of federal funds
because in all told there's 305 million
and so we've kind of outlined for you
what those are and how those can be used
and how those will be
made available to the districts
okay so um
[Music]
yeah i remember that that whole thing
but i
you had said at the time that this
second tranche of money
had not gone out so when do you expect
that this next tranche will go out
so it should be fairly soon um so
just to be clear of the 34 million that
we've already made available to the
district since last may
only 7 million has been accessed and so
these funds can be used
for the same kinds of things the only
reason we haven't actually made them
available yet is
in order to accommodate these grant
funds in our grant management system
we had to hire a programmer to be able
to make modifications to the system to
kind of replicate that grand
infrastructure
for this grant i believe that that
contract has now been approved
and so they'll be making those
modifications to the system once the
system is set up
then the schools will be able to go into
the grant management system and access
those funds
in the meantime we have already given
them their
preliminary estimates in terms of the
amount of money and the eligible
usage for those funds so they today can
be planning for how they will use those
once
we have the system accessible that they
okay so um do you have
do you have a clue as to when that's
going to actually happen
i would hope in the next couple of weeks
is there i mean because i've heard from
some other folks that
you know i've heard from some schools
saying like hey we want access to these
funds
but i everyone who's asked and says and
there's concern about having access to
those funds still has
access to unused ester one funding
um and so we just encourage them to use
those funds
today if they have an exigent expense
they're saying like we need to spend
money today i'm like
well you have these other funds just
spend those down quite frankly those
expenses are going to expire they have a
shorter timetable
and we want them to use those first and
so
while i have heard from not from many
districts
necessarily but from people outside of
districts saying like when are you going
to make these funds available
in fact the schools have funds available
to do the things they need to get done
i have not come across a district that
is doesn't have funding available to
them
and so again we're working through as
quickly as we can as you all are
familiar with the contracting process at
the state level
to hire somebody and get them to make
the changes and stuff like that
um getting to make the change will be
the easy part getting through the
contracting process would
be the most difficult and so that just
has to happen and then we'll be able to
make those available in the grant
management system do you have
do you have constituents who are
concerned that they need these funds
accidentally and they're not able to
access them
uh no every time i every time i ask
they say things are fine so
uh that's what i'm here to do so
but if we're not if we're not spending
i find it strange to send them more
and that maybe our allocation
method uh
needs to change unless that's federal
law but i think
a law yeah i don't have any input into
that that's how it comes
and just to be clear with the most
recent
um relief act that was passed uh we
would
be receiving additional funds um i
haven't seen all of the details
associated with that but
you know potentially as much as 300
million more
yeah uh representative murray you have a
question
yes thank you is there a drop dead date
at which these funds have to
all be used and is that going to create
a problem that you might foresee
so i don't they have to be allocated by
you have a pretty good runway on that
but that was the cares act right the
first one
no that funding is um oh yeah that's
september 22 i said obligated so the
has to be spent by that day but this one
is obligated by 22
spent by 23. okay that was the 900 well
whatever the 100
156 right okay okay so
all right so we do have we do have quite
a
runway um to access those funds
and truthfully you know we will have the
funds out and available but one of the
things that is
kind of a priority for those funds from
the u.s department of education
is really around learning loss and
summer programming and what we're going
well i will be surprised if school
systems that
don't have summer school would be able
to gin up summer school
especially for the young kids
you know that i mean i realize the older
kids are having
problems as well but uh the
the real problem is down in the uh in
the younger kids
but that's my that's my assessment
overall
okay thank you so let's go to
school let's see this is on page 1258
which is school nutrition state
okay so we know that
everybody that wants a free lunch once
what is going on with this money for the
future
uh well so we even in order to be
eligible
for our federal food and nutrition
grants from the u.s department of
agriculture
we have a mass i believe this match goes
back you know
decades in terms of the amount of match
they haven't
increased it but we have to continue to
spend a certain
level of state funds in order to be
eligible to participate in the usda
funding so this you know would be
required if we want to continue to
receive those
usda funds okay and what is the
state fund non-match
so this is uh basically the state
breakfast reimbursement funding that
there was a bill that was passed on that
so they basically uh so you have
free and you have reduced and just
basically took away kind of a reduced
category just made them
i i i yeah i'm not sure i understood
what you said but
i'll get it so some students qualify for
free
um and so then they're providing their
meals for free other students
are qualified as reduced and so they're
contributing
maybe 30 cents per meal or something
like that um
and so this with a piece of legislation
that was passed that
eliminated the reduce then just made it
great
okay thank you uh representative murray
thank you again can you pop back a page
to 1257
and start the story with a federal grant
looks like it's been cut
pretty much in half can you speak to
that and how that's
impacts going on to the next couple
pages
can you tell me what line item you're on
um
seventy-two on pages
from 57 to 2500 actually
i'm gonna let you wait on that one looks
2.5 million um
so this is we get in like
seven different grants from the federal
government
and we are trying to realign them
into our state accounting units the way
that we
so that this we made some changes so
that we can do
reporting to the federal government
easier on our side
you'll see on previous page on 1256
class 72 went up
so this is us realigning on our site so
that we can report to the federal
government
easier
so there was no there were no dollars
lost it's just that
if you add up all those they still come
out to the same thing
or at least to our estimate of the grant
and then in addition to that we have the
code of grants that we got
from the usda as well representative
heath you have a question
thank you um would it be possible
there's a lot of that
in this budget and where you move things
around
are there footnotes or are there things
that that would help us to better
understand
what you've done through this budget um
that would kind of be a a
a walk through the changes that you've
made
i don't know if that counts um
it's pretty much all in my head
uh uh i i could try and put something
together i don't know
if it would make much more sense than
what i'm describing because um
something comes in and something goes
out so it
you know it may be so convoluted but i
can certainly try
okay thank you it's just it's confusing
because step is
is all changed around and unless you're
here to tell us what the change is
and of the reduction in one place and
increase in another place
and then right so i i do think i mean
at a very high level if you look at the
last page of the budget
on 1290 1295
so it shows the department of
education's federal general and other
funds
and that you can really see you know our
federal funds changes
you know the predicted increase in
federal funds
some of the general funds which has
actually decreased about five million
dollars and our other funds which has
decreased as well other funds is
inclusive of the education trust fund
the majority of that decreases relative
to the decrease in adequacy
and then you can also see the number of
positions the um so we had 282 positions
proposed last year as opposed to 289
um i know it's super super high level so
you can't see you know tammy had a
position in her side of the budget
that's now in my
side but um that might be kind of
at least a helpful part to look at okay
i guess it would be helpful because you
know looking at what you're saying
caitlyn you get that sense that there's
an
arc but um there's still that gap
between does that mean there's been a
loss or
just a move to someplace else in terms
of some of the fun so yeah it's a
it's quite the string puzzle to sort it
out
okay um the next
is on for me is on page 1262
uh it looked like there was no money
in 20 we put
100 000 in 21
and now we're at 50 000.
so can somebody talk about this please
sure so we had initially budgeted last
time a hundred thousand
um and this is to pay for advanced
placement tests for our
students principally we target
economically disadvantaged students in
you don't see any spending there because
of the pandemic
that disrupted the ap exam and
college board went to an all online
assessment
and basically provided they themselves
provided scholarships to students so we
weren't we didn't need to at that point
in time
we had budgeted 100 000 but again trying
to meet
the requirement for uh the budget
parameters that we had
with the hundred thousand we were able
to pay for almost all of our ap
not just our economically disadvantaged
kids and the fifty thousand dollars will
allow us to meet mission of paying for
economically disadvantaged kids that
okay so the 50
000 in each year
is basically to pay for
the advanced placement test exactly the
yep
do the when do those tests take place at
the end of the school year
okay and who provides who
who provides the tests so the test is
um administered in the school but it's a
college board test
so it's by sap by college board
okay so if i'm taking um
advanced calculus which i
i'm lucky i can add one and one but if
i'm taking advanced calculus
the college board to get that test
so the student would and generally it's
done through their ap teacher the
student would sign
up to take the test right so that the
school is teaching the ap
class all year long and then they get
towards the end and the student says i'm
going to take the ap
test so the student would sign up and
that student would be required to pay a
fee to
um college board but we get a roster
from the schools of the
qualified students and so we pay
directly to college board
the tuition for those qualified students
do we know what is this a straight fee
for
the same for all classes all courses
i believe it is yes okay
he's like 84 80 84
okay
okay i know
you guys shouldn't give me um
i'm gonna actually have to jump off in
about two minutes i just want to let you
know that
then okay okay
i'm going to the cte program
page
and and 1267
eliminated the money for the dropout
prevention
i am obviously uh
somewhat concerned did we put it in
someplace else
or so we did not uh rep on burger that
was one of the
decisions that we made through the
budget process
um and i think i um may have alluded to
this previously but just let me refresh
kind of lunch because again we're trying
to meet our budget
so we're trying to figure out where we
can make reductions and where we cannot
and so my choice for this program
really stems from the fact that this
came into fruition back i think in 2008
uh where the state saw a high drop out
rate that they were uncomfortable with
and wanting to do some type of an
intervention
the circumstances on the ground today
are not that we
do a good job making sure through a
variety of different programs
that we don't have a high dropout rate
and that many of our students stay
in school and so it's almost like
end of life we started a program it was
successful we were able to
see reductions in our dropout rate we
were able to meet the goal of the
program
and accomplishment accomplish it and so
then rather than have kind of that
classic government program that never
ends this one
of the different programs that we had
appears to have
uh more so than not met mission and
would be
a good place to redirect those resources
at something else potentially
yeah can you say a little bit more about
that because i mean there was a
time i think it was new jersey decided
well we don't have polio anymore so
we're going to get rid of the vaccine
which is you know kind of you don't have
polio because you have a vaccine
so can you speak a little bit more about
getting rid of this program
one might speculate that the dropout
rate would thereby increase
so one of the things you know we would
hope that it wouldn't increase
uh but probably one of the things that
has been most impactful over the years
on dropout prevention was really an
action of the legislature so
when they increased compulsory education
to 18.
so now the students are in school until
and that affords them a runway and
latitude for the schools to be able to
work with them to be able to help them
navigate
through to their high school diploma and
then the other program that
you have supported that legislature has
supported consistently over the years
that has made a significant difference
in terms of our dropouts is our adult
education programming
our adult ed programs serve many of
these
at-risk students and by doing so
keep them engaged and are able to bring
them through to a high school diploma
at relatively significant numbers we
have about 1400 students across the
state
who are between the ages of 16 and 18
involved in our adult education program
and then the third event that has taken
place over the last decade since this
was first put in place really is
i would point to many of our charter
schools
i believe it's about eight of our
charter schools are specifically
targeted at at-risk
students so these are charter schools
that are in place in order to help those
kids who are at risk
and work specifically with them and so
probably it's a combination of it was
appropriate at the time we got this
program started
you start making a dent there's been
some other policy decisions over the
last decade
that seem to have made a significant
impact
and therefore that's why we find
ourselves where we are today i don't
know if that helps you but
okay um this is moving on to
i'm going to have to jump out rep on
burger i apologize i have a quote
there's school leaders that knew and i
need to be honest so
no problem okay guys
somebody will be able to answer the
questions um
this is on adult education
and i noticed that the federal funds
are like 2.2 and 2.3
but when we look at the state funds
it's costing us 4.1
million and
i guess that my real question is why
does it cost the state twice as much as
the grant
um so my understanding of that program
is that we are required to provide
a match and as
we have provided more match throughout
the years now we're at a level of
requiring
that match and maintaining that
maintenance of effort
and if we don't maintain that
maintenance of effort then we lose the
federal funds on
as well as if we reduce the state funds
then we end up losing the federal funds
so it is a high maintenance of effort i
do agree
um unfortunately we've kind of set that
so
are we making giant strides with adult
education
uh i i guess that that would be a
programmatic question i would have to
defer to the program administrator on
that
um i i would think that she would say
yes
it is a very helpful program um but
i can always ask her to
answer the question and get back to you
if that's what you'd like
i i would have i would appreciate that
because
uh and i guess that the the other half
of the question is
is how much of this adult education
money
is going to the children that
uh commissioner edelblue talked about
as being in an adult head
i mean i can tell you that our adult ed
program here
not very robust and um
but what is robust is the kids that are
in the um adult education programs
with our eagle academy so
i just need to i just need to have an
understanding about
sorry i'm so full of questions but this
is a
extremely interesting
um budget
a lot of their own so you're helping me
just go through this too
oh i'm letting you flag it i don't need
to this is great
now i'm on page 12
79 and
this is
vocational this is the workforce
innovation innovation
and the uh vocational rehab
this is this is for the people
that have some sort of
that okay that are that the state the
state provides
money for their education
um it's to help them get back to the
um
and this is that 3.4 million dollars is
the state match that is required
oh christine you're there would you like
to talk about the vr program
yep that is exactly right it's a it's a
program for
students as well as adults that
people who are disabled or perhaps maybe
had some sort of injury that occurred in
their lifetime
our counselors do work with individuals
to find pathways that they can be
how how does oh i'm sorry representative
maria have a question no
you can keep going i can always wait but
i was going to ask if you have
um i don't know a return on you know you
get these people back
into the workforce a return on the i
guess return on investment
is the standard phrase of
how much we get back for helping these
i don't have an actual number but i can
i can figure that out but i know that we
have um
changed our programs up so that that um
the
employees that kind of connect them with
the workforce they'll have things like
the longer that they're in a job
the benefits that they get um insurance
there's an increase with some of our
contractors and their pay because we
want to
have them have be successful in the
how does oh did you have another
you're you're muted ma'am okay
i'm sorry i thought i had pressed that
hard enough uh
how does this program interact with uh
the health and human services programs
that are out there for these uh these
so i believe that some of the um one in
one
of the ways they support um in the iep
meetings
we make sure that they have
long-term like that there's counseling
going on so that
if they're new if there's long-term
supports needed
it is discussed in the iep meeting and
then the department of health and human
services can then
know how many students or how many folks
might be in that same category
so that's one way in which vr works with
i've always worried about duplication of
of services and finances
between health and human services and
doe
but that's i guess that's going to
happen
so i i was i was mainly concerned if you
are
in fact engaging
with the folks at health and human
services because
you know that they've already
if the child is over 20
21 is that the at the cutoff age
if the child is over 21 or the person
is over 21 then uh you know health and
human services
picks it up and i just wanted to be sure
that the education
part of it is interwoven
into whatever their either
past iep or current is uh
is working on you're absolutely correct
and i think one of the how we
work with some of coordination is we
want to make sure that department health
and human services know who these
students
are because if not there are a lot of
students who can't get services till
a young till an older age so we
make sure that they know that the
coordination is happening at the iep
meeting
and they even talk about the planning
happening in the sophomore year
so that by the time their seniors
department health and human service
folks know that
right but the school system picks it up
until they're 21 and
um and so but
you work with children
that are um under 21 as well is that
correct
yes yep and we have sts counselors in
the department
that are in our vocational um rehab we
kind of restructure it so there's five
we call them sts counselors to make sure
that they're getting attention
that they're that they have a pathway
after school
and so some of the students go right
into the workforce
and then some of them um depending on
how complicated the issues are
would be passed on maybe or working with
department health and human services
okay are there any questions there
all right uh seeing none let's go
over to um the uh
um i got sarah wheeler on if you'd like
to go back to that adult ed question
oh sure that'd be fine um can you
phrase the question to her so she can
have the context
sarah i was i was talking about the
adult ed
program and uh the
the dollars obviously which is uh what i
what i was concerned about
but
i'm not i'm not sure
how successful the adult ed program
is in the state
and that um we
we have quite a bit of money focused on
it
and yet uh
i see mary but i i'm just
i just am you know
obviously i don't want to eliminate the
program that's not
that's not what my what my goal is but
i think we have been more successful
at the um
high school level
[Music]
with the adult education program than we
have
with adults and so i'm
i'm just trying to uh to come to grips
with
are we focusing on the right kinds of
things that
so adult education runs
two different types of programs one of
them is under the workforce innovations
and opportunities act
which is the workforce development and
that is for anybody who is not
enrolled in school or not required to be
enrolled in school
so in that program we don't serve
anybody under the age of 18.
is that excuse me is that in cooperation
the unemployment folks yes so
we are a core partner um title two is
one of the four titles in
the workforce innovations and
opportunities act so we are
we are all of title ii and the services
that we provide
under under that are designated as
basic literacy english as a second
language with the goal of transitioning
individuals um into post-secondary
education training
and or employment
about 60 percent of the students that we
serve in that are english language
learners
between three and five thousand students
in in the not
in total adult ed or just in no
that's just in our wioa adult ed program
so we also have an adult diploma program
and that we have a number of those
around the states and in that
program students earn credits towards a
high school diploma
or a high school equivalency work on
preparing for the high school
equivalency
in that program under
state law we are allowed to
work with 16 and 17 year olds if they
are they remain enrolled in school and
they're enrolled in adult education so
that may be what you're referring to
when you say that the services
are working with our high school
students
um i will tell you that when that
program was started back in the
i want to say the 80s there were
probably 100
students that were still enrolled in
high school um and in the last couple of
years been closer to 1500 to
1600 students who are still enrolled in
high school who are
also earning credits through the adult
um and that actually has gone up since
um just more of a comment um i just want
i'm a big fan of adult education
always have been as a former high school
teacher
manchester has a robust program as does
nashua
we've seen hundreds and hundreds of
students who become disenfranchised with
the traditional
public school system or who are
fallen into some kind of a hardship
where they have to have a full-time job
and adult education has become the
vehicle
by which they can get a diploma or an
equivalency
we've also seen a lot of students who
need a kind of a refresher course in
mathematics
will often take an adult ed class
in math in order to get into the
community
college or a four-year college because
their math skills just aren't
up to par so adult education is a
i mean through my lens and the data i
think
supports it has been very productive
in the state of new hampshire and a big
help
since we changed the graduation
age to 18 we've seen a lot of students
matriculate through adult education very
successfully
thank you i i like i said i wasn't
uh i'm not opposed to the adult ed
program i'm just wasn't sure um
what what we were including in there and
i think that sarah probably helped me a
little bit uh
including the geds
and the those kinds of things which
are which are extremely important
so thank you very much i appreciate it
sarah by the way i like your background
thank you it's new hampshire
are there any other questions
doesn't look like it so
i want to thank everybody that came this
morning
and you did a good job explaining things
i think helping us all um
we have no idea where we're going with
the budget
at this time we've gathered a lot of
information and um
we've got uh we got a lot of work to do
and i guess uh
mickey is there anything in hb2
i mean we've got the change relative to
the free reduced lunch adm
which will come up when you talk about
school funding we'll deal with that then
there was the new hampshire scholars
program the extension of the
authority to accept the grants gifts
donations for that accounting unit
you do have a couple retain bills
relative to education
that you know the committee will
probably want to consider uh
those in relation to house bill 2
whether or not you're going to want to
add anything from those bills to house
bill 2.
but nothing i don't think we haven't
okay and uh yeah and we do have a couple
of bills
that are still need to uh
to come to us yeah i think we were
referred a couple
uh second committee bills one relative
to school building aid and one relative
to
special education aid and the new uh
risk
shared risk pool uh proposal um
neither of those we have we've had a
work session on yet so
yeah we'll figure that out for soon
yes representative heath if the folks
from doe want to go
you may just ask them a quick question
is there anything else that they'd like
to tell us that
we didn't ask them that they'd like to
share with us in terms of their budget
okay you can stay or you can leave
that's okay
mickey we'll have to uh we'll have to
schedule those things shortly
i think everybody saw that um
the the drop dead dates in the calendar
has changed
and um that's going to
um make it particularly difficult i
think is the right term
for us because um
we may or may not have uh
positions you know house positions on
things
that um maybe should
go into uh hb2
so it's um
i don't know well we'll we'll stumble
along and do the best we can
but
we'll we'll manage somehow but
uh so no meeting tomorrow
wednesday thursday and friday
and friday is going to be the um
university system and we're going to
talk about that in the uh in the morning
their cost saving measures
and then we'll press on to
the combination of
the two systems uh represent murray you
have a question
yeah thank you is uh margie smith going
to be joining us for that i thought that
there was some
possibility that she may be sitting in
i don't know i have i need to call her
and i'll probably
do that tomorrow can i have one other
thing related unrelated to this
andrea asked about covid there's someone
in our neighborhood who received moderna
for their first vaccine and pfizer for
the second
cdc doesn't even know what to do about
that so when you go
and they checked at every they checked
they checked they checked at the very
end when the nurse came out this was the
tuesday when it was so windy and cold
and everyone was miserable
uh they were injected with the wrong
vaccine and they've been in touch with
cdc and it's like
they don't really know what this means
but i'm sure it's not the only time it's
happened
but for all of us going in when you go
for your second time double double
double triple check that when they put
it in your arm it's the right one
thank you public service announcement so
that was a that's a great public service
announcement
[Music]
yeah so i don't know
um i representative he
said that she has a doctor's appointment
on the 22nd
and so on that date we won't do any
voting
uh because she won't be available and i
think it's only appropriate that we
when we are doing any voting that
everybody that can
uh everybody that's here needs to be
here
and so because we've all heard
we've all heard the testimony um
they're still trying to come to grips
with
when we're going to have the public
hearing
um for there's a
proposal for one at four o'clock in the
afternoon
and then one at nine o'clock in the
morning
and so we'll have to uh sort
ourselves through that um
and uh try to
try to get ourselves together on that
we have to be finished is it the 29th
mickey
so i think the 26th is a friday
and that was the original drop dead date
that i had for all of the division
decisions to be made by
that was assuming we would have a house
a full committee exec session that
following
monday tuesday wednesday somewhere and
there so that would give us time to put
it all together before we have a full
finance exec um
i don't know if anything's changing with
um
you know like if there's house session
days that fall anywhere and it screws up
the
the exact days for the finance committee
i will cross that bridge when we come to
it but i think right now we're we're
still shooting for the division
recommendations to be complete by
friday the 26th okay
that that sounds good so um
have a great afternoon
we need to make sure that we we look
through
uh safety and transportation
to see what's going on there because
we've got a we've got a six million
dollar problem
at least so um
that's uh that's our next uh
our next thing as far as um
what's going on with the education fund
we've got
a significant
problem there as well so
um i know it says uh
you know if you don't have money in the
education fund you can take it from the
general fund but oh by the way
the general fund doesn't have the money
and so
we have to uh figure out how
within the education trust fund we can
at least
semi get to zero because that
is a uh that is it's an issue
and um i think we've all you know we all
know
that ways and means and my humble
opinion
cheated us but that's my opinion i can't
uh i wasn't there but
um we need to uh we need to try to
think about that and
what's available and i agree
with many of representative he's
comments
that you know we really need this
program back
and i don't disagree but what program
are we going to eliminate
to get that program back and that's
that's the um
those are the decisions that we'll be
making
in a couple weeks so think about them
and
um we'll we'll see what happens
so it's uh quarter after 12 almost 20
after 12.
uh thank you all for being here and
we'll see you wednesday morning
not bright and early but after we've had
our first cup of coffee